[Music]
in Rachel Dolezal news oh she's still
around who that who that would it was
the white woman who pretend to be a
black woman oh she looked like she was
Donald she looks like Clark black no but
she was straight up like white hair
turning white you know I mean like
butter shining yeah yeah I mean
submitted by cuddle season that's true
a transracial florida man born white
claims he is actually no this is Rachel
Dolezal I've been wanting to be
transracial for a long time race you
want to be all the cultures of the world
so just brown know like I want it gray
you want to be great I want to wear like
traditional clothes of that world but
not be like if there's your cultural
appropriation because when people like
like you know like the dashiki like it's
super colorful and I want to just wear
it because it looks cool it's mad
comfortable yeah well like no but you
know maybe I want to be a rock well you
know how you know it's when you're
wearing a dashiki right and they're like
you're not [ __ ] whatever blah blah
blah then you ask yourself is this even
their mind they're like oh [ __ ] oh if
you like if you know the language and
the culture it's like man you can't say
[ __ ] to me East Africa oh you're just
like I'm supporting the culture by
paying for this or it's like [ __ ] you
mind your own business
yeah but it'd be kind of weird if I saw
and what I she got me caught cracking up
though actually it'd be normal for my
nation
yeah I just love it where I didn't want
to explore because like why do we have
to all wear jeans and t-shirts I don't
know if that would be considered
transracial though apparently here with
transracial means is when you actually
identify as that other maybe for a week
I want to be African I want to identify
as Hawaiian Hawaiian Hawaii is kind of
interesting though because I feel like
Hawaiian culture is so accepting it's
very different from other like cultures
because when I was in Hawaii I accept me
I was kicking it with a bunch of locals
and there was a couple of cats do was
like the dreaded Allison why do here and
there and there
he was like well like being Hawaiian how
he explained to me it's not even like
race or skin colored thing it's like if
you accept the culture and you do what
we do then you'll just be quiet
the state of mind I feel like that's
what should be everywhere like if you're
not making fun of it and like trying to
like make it look fat on purpose you
know because you're like it's only the
making that look bad on purpose thing
with the whole cultural appropriation
it's about like oh now you're just using
this as to make it cool for your race
but in our race when you actually wear
it whatever you're trying to wear make
it cool it's actually look like we get
ridiculed for it or something like
that's what I guess it's like it's like
this it's like when dudes used to wear
like cornrows our [ __ ] was a side of
being get up but now white girls are
having cornrows now it's cool no it's
cool so it's like you get to take all
the positive way from my culture but I
gotta stick with this negative stimuli
so is it cultural appropriation that I'm
wearing western clothes like white
people shirt white people pass western
clothing and culture has been affected
everywhere all around the world so
that's just a general truth you know go
to Japan or Asia or China
everyone's wear the t-shirt everybody
everybody's wearing at each no matter
where you're at is world so there's no
there's there's no like distinction
between that versus like something else
like you know there's an issue with like
music and hip-hop you know so hip-hop
originally like what it started out what
people say out in the East Coast and
there's a way of people expressing
themselves or whatever and then it was
very weird to hear something that was so
underground and gritty that was you know
about like expressing yourself during
like oppressive times where a white
person would do it because they're like
that's not that's not your [ __ ] that was
hard things this is this is where we
express ourselves I'm not sure a Manila
but now it's evolved you know I mean so
now we move past that where it's now
it's just like this dope form of music
where people no matter who you are you
can express it but it took time for them
yeah there's a lot of white people in
underground hip-hop like huge audiences
and everywhere yeah yeah so here we have
Adam wheeler
aka dude he now or she now goes by
douchey so not only transsexual trans
racial
double trans yeah so they cancel each
other out there she she's a female
Filipino or he's a white man that became
a female Filipino there you go
Filipino confusing mmm doo dee dee Moore
he lives in Florida and Lord Florida
Florida glory Island Florida
yeah so she was saying that she would
watch The History Channel for hours and
times and whenever it would come on
nothing else intrigued her more than the
Filipino culture so she was just watch
ours affiliate in Filipino culture
documentaries and stuff and so she had
nurse no she's not she's not Filipino
Shaiful Philippine she does drive a tuk
tuk in Tampa tripping you mean like a
jeep me that means she's stupid that's
all you do with you being Filipino I
don't know one Filipino that drives that
yeah like I've never even seen that but
apparently this is something that they
have and in the Philippines not in
[ __ ] Miami or like [ __ ] Orlando
yeah right so then he's bringing it mad
racist a little bit even Filipinos don't
drive tuk tuks here yeah you're not
gonna go to Eagle Rock and see [ __ ] 20
tuk tuks around there that's like if I
[ __ ] ran to Bart's house with the cart
thing shopping cart the rickshaw culture
yeah that's like that's like lightweight
offensive yo yeah she's a water buffalo
yeah get the [ __ ] out it is ridiculous
you're just saying that she she created
a facebook page facebook page for
transracial people cuz she thought that
she was alone you are alone you feel
just similar to like transsexuals where
they feel like there is they're just not
in the right body make aliyah were born
and
the opposite body so she's just saying
like she feels like she was just born in
the wrong body as though as a white man
you know what sucks about this I feel
like you know how like there's a color
so extreme when they were talking about
like people accepting who are like
transsexual right they're like what's
next you know are you'd be
transformational I know like what the
[ __ ]
slippery slope but it actually happened
yeah like this like I feel like this is
ridiculous yeah that seems to be trans
pcs there's a lizard man how many people
are gonna count like ya told you [ __ ]
dogs are the [ __ ] dog get me out of
jail all right oh yeah that's crazy this
this is it because I feel like when you
go transgender and I'm not saying like
accept or not accept or anything is no
right and wrong but it's like um it's
like genetics right you're talking about
like being born a certain way or feeling
certain way or like you you won't your
hormones you can't control the way that
you feel about certain things it's
biological
yeah whereas transracial seems a lot of
like more like cultural preference yeah
right because you have to learn that
stuff to understand what you do or don't
learn and she said herself when I was a
kid I was watching that's all I saw on
TV like you know what I mean that's some
different [ __ ] they should have got him
cable they're just putting a word behind
we exactly like making it more I don't
know official
they're trying to officialize something
that already exists a wannabe yeah this
isn't new this has been going on for a
long time where you had that one white
guy with all black friends that thought
he was also black or you have this asian
kid with all these white kids that they
think he's a heel I you know like it's
it exists this is just very extreme
enough to be in some sort of news yeah
I'm translationally and and in
conjunction with the transgender just
makes it a very extreme thing I mean
again no no shader hey it's just very
interesting I wonder if he goes around
and tries to spread like awareness about
the Filipino culture the entire does
lectures or like corrects other
Filipinos on how to be Filipino
see bad [ __ ] that's gonna be [ __ ]
hilarious he made her speak like Tagalog
or Ilocano or some [ __ ] or is it wrong
for us to say he or she looks like if if
the woman looks like a heat i'ma call or
a see even if it's a biological woman
what's her name
I'll be like sir that's already a fake
Filipino me where she goes through well
she was born
Adam wheeler should have been ran out or
something should have been Francine or
oh yeah grace hope I need to know for my
Filipinos cuz I never heard of jadoo so
is that a common Filipino name please
let me know write it right now yeah cuz
I don't I never heard of a job it is
still jadoo wheeler I know I was a joke
Batista was it just job and do john-paul
ever only went there they run this
article here when she was pressed about
cultural appropriation or the adopting
of other cultures claiming them as their
own
she replied quote I believe people will
take advantage just like other people
have taken advantage of their identity
to get their way but the difference
between me and them is that I don't want
that I think we all have the freedoms to
pursue happiness in our own ways if
someone feels that they feel at home
with a certain religion a certain race a
certain culture I think if that's who
they really feel inside life is about
finding out who you are the more
knowledge you have of yourself the
happier you can be I think that true way
to find out is you have to scare them so
if he's taking a shower and you scare
holy [ __ ] that is Adam wheeler
yeah oh my god what happened
she's jaw dude yeah
you're Filipino I know they identified
that's your real I gotta see how she
liked that stuff tissue yeah if you
point with the lips yes I've seen it
yeah all the time they do also what I
think we got good Filipino radars and
obviously JA dude keep I don't know does
it well does she listen to Whitney
Houston does she karaoke constantly I
gotta see these things do Joe Kent is
jadoo employed in the medical field or a
model a nurse is JA do have a cousin
named jr. oh yeah dewpoints with his
lips or her lips or is she have a shoe
collection but she's broke yeah never
shows up on time
[Music]
[Music]